good evening everyone it's great to be
here so a big thank you at the outset to
intelligence squared to our great panel
and to all of you for being here our
discussion tonight the theme China
Friend or Foe
so before we get started with panel
let's just check what your thoughts are
let's just check the mood of the room
with a quick show of hands so all those
who start with the position China friend
could you give me a hands up I'm going
to get I'm gonna get the panel to help
me measure how many do you think roughly
that is show of hands percentage of the
room it's probably about 30 something
about 30 okay China foe hands up
probably roughly the same so does that
leave about 40% of don't knows how many
of you are don't knows let's have a show
of hands yeah I would say a third a
third a third sense Malcolm and so
obviously a huge question and in no
particular order
I just thought earlier today random news
stories running through my head some of
the things that have happened in the
last few days the last few weeks a
Chinese billionaire described Australia
as a giant baby after it revoked his
visa over inference operations some of
the big corporations caterpillar Apple
Jaguar Land Rover warned that China's
economic slowdown was damaging their
sales and damaging their profits a
Chinese ambassador accused Canada of
white supremacy after the arrests as you
will remember of a huawei senior Huawei
executive in Canada and then the
subsequent arrests of two Canadians and
death sentence for a third career
in China China landed on the far side of
the Moon an Air New Zealand flight was
turned around in midair enroute from
Auckland to Shanghai reportedly due to
problems over references to Taiwan in
its documentation closer to home here
the UK seen more applications for entry
to you its universities from China and
Wales in early 2019 or sorry from China
and Hong Kong in early 2019
then it that it has from China and where
those good combo and the UK chancellor's
checker just to finish off this little
random list of stories the UK Chancellor
of the Exchequer had his visit to China
cancelled after the UK defense secretary
said a new aircraft carrier would be
deployed to honor freedom of navigation
mission to the South China Sea when its
operational the hua wayside cyber
security evaluation center said it could
only give a limited assurance that there
was no national security threat from
Juarez operations in telecoms in this
country the national cyber security
center said risk should be manageable
talks to avert an escalation in the
trade war between the world's two
economic superpower continue
so China friend or foe it is a complex
question as just that brief list
demonstrates but we will attempt to
navigate it this evening and to make it
a little easier to do so we're going to
divide the discussion into three parts
we're going to start with economics and
economic relations we're then going to
move on to security and then we're going
to have a discussion about values and
obviously all these three shade into one
another but we'll roughly follow that
that route let me now introduce the
panel who are going to do the work for
us on the question of China friend or
foe so at the far end Martin wolf who is
associate editor and chief economics
commentator at the Financial Times
his most recent book the shifts and the
shocks what we've learned and have still
to learn from the financial crisis
cohdon in the middle beijing bow and
professor of economics at the London
School of Economics and Caillou is a
specialist in macro economics
international macroeconomics that is and
the Chinese economy and closest to me
Sir Malcolm Rifkind a bettering
conservative politician who served as
defense secretary and foreign secretary
and in the mid nineties as foreign
secretary he managed the last stages of
the handover of Hong Kong to China he is
also more recently chaired the Commons
Intelligence and Security Committee
which oversees the work of mi5 mi6 and
GCHQ so enough for me I'd like to ask
each of you three now to give us a brief
outline of your top answer to the
question China Friend or Foe Marty do
you want to get us started you have one
minute max - okay well I'm very much in
the with the third group who refused to
choose between friend or foe and I think
that's the right position to take the
first reason is I don't think it's a
very helpful category in thinking about
our relationship with this country and
the second reason which I think it's
very very important is that whether
China turns out to be a friend or foe
depends only to a modest degree on
objective circumstances but I think to a
very considerable degree on how we treat
it so we're working very hard
particularly the u.s. to make it a foe
but that's not because of the intrinsic
nature of the relationship but because
of how we behave we are important actors
the key point to understand is that
China is an enormous ly important
reality a huge power a huge country
non-western with a very different system
of armor ours and what we are going to
have to do is work out a relationship
which is as productive as it possibly
can be because it's not going away
and so I define her of the proper
relationship and have done so in several
pieces as beep as one of I hope
productive competition and cooperation
and managing that balance is what our
future in the world is going to depend
on thank you
I think the world needs more friends
these days than foes and it's important
to cast China and the light right light
on the one hand the world in the West
tells China well you are a big country
it's time to take up greater
responsibilities and on the other hand
it Shasta sizes China for too much
engagement but what is too much
engagement it has become one of the
largest financial supporter to
international organizations UN
peacekeeping it is funding about 340
billion dollars of infrastructure
infrastructure deficit in the world and
offering sixty billion dollars of
financial assistance to Africa for every
one dollar that the u.s. spends on a
clean energy investment China spends
three and it's spending about it's
taking up about half of the global
investment now on renewable energy more
importantly China is deeply enmeshed in
the global system it does well when
other countries do well that is probably
the single most compelling a reason for
why China is supporting globalization
and upholding multilateralism so the
important thing I completely agree with
Martin is how do we align the interests
of China with the interest of the rest
of the world and demonizing China is not
going to solve some of the deeper
intractable issues in Western liberal
democracies but demonizing it could have
potentially lead to self-fulfilling
prophecies thank you and welcome well we
hope China would be a friend it now
looks as if it may end up as a foe but I
think as we speak that the jury's still
out
what is clear is that the single most
important political development of this
century will be the emergence of China
as the other superpower the United
States since the end of the Soviet Union
has had it all to itself I would make a
couple of points that limit what China
has achieved I is quite obviously a
dramatic transformation but you know
what China is doing now in terms of its
economic strength is where China ought
to have been 50 years ago and if it
hadn't been for the lunacy of multi-tone
great leaps forward Cultural Revolution
we've always known that's where China
would end up where they are now we know
that because other Chinese societies
whether it's Taiwan where it's Hong Kong
whether it's Singapore all effectively
Chinese have shown that they are
exceptionally good capitalist so China
has caught up with them it hasn't yet
overtaken them second point is that
China would have the world believe that
there is they represent an alternative
model to the West because of their in
remarkable economic achievements and
that you don't want to have the kind of
democratic societies that we aspire to
or actually enjoy that to is a false
argument because when you think about it
the other Asian countries of a
comparable economic success to China
Taiwan Japan South Korea not only have a
comparable economic achievement but they
have done so combined with the rule of
law and combined with democratic
societies for their citizens so the
final point I make and is that we're not
talking at a choice between Western
values and Chinese characteristics what
we are talking about is whether China
will eventually realize that its own
people are entitled to the same
liberties not just as Western countries
but as their Asian neighbors in Japan
South Korea and Taiwan and then the
question of friend or foe will become
much easier to address and resolve thank
you well thank you to all three of you
for setting out your stools there now
we're going to divide up a bit
start with the economics and drill down
into that and so Martin I wonder if you
could set us off with this question
I mean if we've been having this
conversation three years ago four years
ago five years ago under a Cameron
Osbourne government the talk was of a
golden era when when it was all about
the friend what went wrong to that I
think the and probably two things have
happened and the second is far the more
important the the first thing that has
happened is a sense in the world outside
and I think it's a sense which is not
entirely unreasonable not unfounded that
the Chinese economy itself has very
substantial problems that the
transitions it's going through are now
very very complex the government is not
completely in control of what's going on
and some of the directions it's taking
and Malcolm is touched on that in terms
of the relationship between the state
and the economy are not ones which many
economists in the West think are going
to work very well there's a recent very
interesting book by one Western
specialist Nikhil Rd which really
emphasizes this idea that this is a
block transition perhaps that's one way
of thinking about it but the second
reason much the more important is that
Western policymakers and above all
American policymakers have decided that
the rise of China is a major strategic
threat and this has several dimensions
and it's just sort of taken little while
to notice one is that if you couldn't
broadly define it the left-of-center has
come to the view very much like mother
well you know they're never going to
become a democracy as we thought they
would that's very problematic we don't
like that but the the bigger element of
it is which is
I think the view of the strategic
community in America and quite a big
chunk of them of the thie of the
corporate community is that these people
are a serious threat they have immense
resources the defense build-up is very
substantial and they are getting ahead
technologically in some very important
areas and we are far too dependent upon
them in fact the very interdependence
which I very much agree is so valuable
they find frightening and this paranoia
I think has now become a dominant
element in American thinking and it's
shaping mr. Trump's policies above all
in trade policy which we're going to get
to and it has shifted very quickly and I
think very much across the board
American attitudes but we're also seeing
it now even in Europe notably very
interesting paper recently from the
German industrial Confederation which
was basically saying you know the
Chinese technology policy it's a threat
to Germany this is a big change and it's
happened quite recently I asked you
about this do you think that this
compares the sense of fear competition
paranoia is that sour grapes is that
just China's just doing a great job of
competing of innovating and actually the
world has woken up from its complacency
and is now right well first of all I
certainly want to see this kind of
tension hostilities a one-way street
china doesn't want to engage with the
world or with the u.s. in this manner
China's economic success has proven to
be well first of all China believes that
it's a populous country and therefore
has to be large necessarily in terms of
trade competition China now recognizes
that yes China has benefited so much
from globalization it's time to give
back it is prepared to pay a higher
price and to bear more responsibilities
and this is probably why we're going to
likely see many concessions to the
tracks a separate question but I suppose
the question that I'm trying to get at
is the argument that that we hear from
you know from Europe and from North
America that it's not a level playing
field
that it's all about no access to markets
it's all about stealing technology and
so on is it that that's the problem or
is it just that China's competing really
well well that's the perception but if
you think about why companies like eBay
and Amazon which had no government
interference whatsoever were driven out
of market is purely because of this
ferocious domestic competition inside
the technological sector within the
country Alibaba is one of 12,000
ecommerce platforms the group buying
business is one of 6,000 so there is a
ferocious competitive environment and
that is why many of the foreign
companies did not strive to compete but
that said they would say they haven't
got any access I mean a lot of them
don't have any access it's just a fact
that's only true of Facebook and Google
that's right information related Bay
competed with Alibaba Amazon is still
there but they're all competed by JD but
that I have to say that landscape is
shifting as well because of the new
sector the Internet economy there's just
much more level playing fields much more
competition it might not have been the
same kind of environment in the past
when we're talking about automobile
manufacturing competition I want to go
back to Martin's point about the blocked
transition do you think there's a sense
in the West that they're kind of looking
at China thinking well you know the
carrots are not looking that great
anymore so maybe we'll treat them as an
enemy now because we can wield a stick
because there's nothing to gain I I
think part of the Trump administration's
attitude to Chinese trade and indeed the
view of people in the number of other
Western countries is sour grapes I mean
the Chinese happen to have been very
successful exporters that's not a unique
Asian phenomenon we have went through
exactly the same with Japan in the 1950s
and with South Korea and other Asian
countries they've shown themselves to be
able to produce the goods that we are
consumers freely choose to buy because
of quality because of price and all the
another other market considerations so
that aspect of it is sour grapes and I
don't go along with the Trump rhetoric
or the Trump analysis however and
there's a huge a lever because what
China has done so far and in a sense you
almost acknowledged it if I may say so
is that they've taken the benefits of
the global economy without this one you
yourself said it's now time to give
something back
and by saying that you were
acknowledging that that's what they have
not been doing up till now and what they
have refused to do in any real sense
apart from rhetoric is to allow Western
companies but not just Western companies
other Asian companies as well to have
the same access to penetrating Chinese
markets as they expect to have when they
proudly go to Davos and say we believe
in globalization and we are now the
champions of globalization
now that Washington has given that up at
this moment in time I hope that will
change but at this moment in time the
ability not just of American companies
but companies from any country other
than China to actually get into the
Chinese market and compete with Chinese
companies is severely restricted not
just because of consumer choice in China
but because the Chinese government
wanted that way and how you do you agree
with that in fact when China joined the
WTO the the the the one of the
conditions were to have certain sectors
be open up to come foreign competition
and foreign companies wanted to come in
for the Chinese market and some even
voluntarily traded in some of their key
technologies now that said those are not
the best companies in the world because
they wanted the Chinese market so that's
that's inaccurate to say that there was
no foreign axis whatsoever there were
certain sectors now today
financial sectors is being liberalized
and they're inviting the foreign
institutions to come in which will be
good for China as well because we need
competition to fix the financial system
problems those kind of regulations those
kind of relaxation of rules have already
happened it's already been completed so
we're seeing that you know Tesla is the
first foreign wholly owned car company
in China and so we're hoping to see more
change which is puzzling them the quest
that the kind of language out of
Washington DC the trade war language
because if things were changing
fundamentally why would the corporate
lobby in the u.s. not be fighting Trump
every step of the way and saying look
the doors open we don't have a problem
here we're happy we're getting the
business that we need in fairness the
trade war has accelerated the opening up
of China which includes not only
financial services but also lowering
tariffs so that Chinese can import more
from abroad now this is a very
for an event that China recorded the
first current account deficit in decades
it's going to import more than it
exports and it will serve as a great
source of aggregate demand but it's
trumpet that the trade war can almost be
said as thought of as a strategic gift
because it's pushing for greater reforms
domestic reforms as well as more opening
up and it's actually consistent with a
long-term economic goals of China I
think Martin I just say does that turn
your argument on its head that you
actually need to treat China a little
bit as a foe or talk to it fairly firmly
in order to get anything done we can
serve the first point is that we can get
through lots and lots of different
examples and I think there's very
substantial faults on both sides at
certain including China we can go
through the details but it seems to me
absolutely clear there are two ways of
approaching this so let's not go one way
which senior Chinese policymakers I've
spoken to are very enthusiastic about
which is force us to open up this was a
policy we adopted towards Japan but
pretty well and essentially there are
two dominant areas here a liberal
liberalization of access the WTO deal
was quite liberal at the time but it
left China as a developing country that
clearly makes less sense now open access
open access for direct investment and
better protection of intellectual
property those are sort of dominant
Western concerns and there's no doubt if
you talk to businesses extensively and I
have that these are legitimate concerns
and there are important elements in the
Chinese government not necessary the
whole system which is huge that wants a
concede on that however it's not at all
clear if you start looking at the
western side that's what they really
want this is what the corporate sector
wants there's no doubt that's what they
want mr. Trump just wants trade to be
balanced but there is very important
elements in the u.s. in particular that
want to disintegrate the economy from
with China to bring the supply chains
back to America
stop Western companies actually
investing in China that's not what they
want at all they want it to be locked
out and the best indication of that of
course is though there are really shoes
here is the history about well ways
they're just a very importantly and
another indicator is that it's becoming
seriously difficult for Chinese
companies to buy Western companies now
we say that they have obstacles to us
where we sure are creating obstacles for
them so we have to decide in a way we
have to decide do we want to open up
China which is probably in their
interest and probably make them more
competitive and increase our integration
with them and mutual interest that's
what I think we should be doing or do we
want to actually lock them out in which
case we guarantee hostility and the
Americans in particular haven't decided
and the Europeans have no idea what
their policy on this is at all
so the western side is a complete mess
but if I understand you correctly you're
saying that it is in some people's
interest in the West to say faux yes
even if the objective reality are you're
asking about why the American corporate
Lobby is not opposing China and white
house Trump policy more effectively
that's because half of the American
corporate people don't want imports into
America they want to they want to have
tariffs because it will give them the
opportunity to sell directly to the
American but uncompetitive producers are
quite excited about this so the the we
have to decide our strategic view of our
futures and the extent to which that
depends on greater economic integration
with China the only difference I would
make but everything Malcolm said about
the comparisons with other Asian
economies is Falls important but China
is ten times as big as Japan so of
course deciding to integrate with China
which you think it's the right decision
to make in the right terms you can
discuss that he's a massive strategic
decision of a different order from the
decision to integration Japan
take that the whole discussion one step
into security now which is obviously
related and you raise hallway mark more
want to put it to you I mean you've
obviously worked on this your committee
when you were on the Security
Intelligence Committee would produce a
report on hallway in the UK telecoms
sector is it a threat hallway well the
United Kingdom's in a unique situation
because when Huawei and British Telecom
had worked together because of the
concerns about security
the British government insisted and the
Chinese company presumably with the
consent of their government agreed to
set up what was called a cell which is
paid for by Huawei but manned by
effectively British intelligence
officials which constantly every day
monitors the way in which Huawei is
using its powers in relation to British
Telecom and whether it's abusing these
powers in any way now there is some
doubt as to how effective that might be
but my own view is that the problem
about whether it's Huawei or other
Chinese companies is not so much these
companies themselves the fundamental
problem is because they are Chinese
companies under Chinese law they would
have to accept instructions from the
Chinese government as to how they
operate I just looked at today that
there's an new national intelligence law
the Chinese passed a couple of years ago
and they're quite open about it are let
me just read one sentence what they say
article 14 of this law grants
intelligence agencies intelligence
agencies when legally carrying forth
their intelligence work may demand that
concerted organs organizations or
citizens provide need as a support and
assistance so what that is means is that
if why we even didn't want to abuse
their power in the UK or that you add
any other country if they were
instructed by Chinese intelligence ie
the Chinese government they would have
no legal right to refuse to cooperate
and that is the concern what do you say
to the argument from some quarters that
this is just hypocrisy on the part of
the West that that the frankly if you
mentioned Edward Snowden if you look at
some of what the US does it's just a
failure no no let me deal with that
point directly if for example the
British government tried to install
British Petroleum or British Telecom or
any British company to actually
interfere with technology in other
countries in order to meet the
requirements of intelligence agencies
British companies would refuse to do
that because there is no legal basis on
which such an instruction could be
issued what you're referring to is
something quite different it's
controversial but it's quite different
it is the right in every country in the
world for intelligence agencies if they
get in a democracy Authority from the
government they can then require the
servers the people who service the
emails and the voicemails and so forth
if there is evidence of terrorists
planning or other threats to national
security to share that information
that's limited to people who are
servicing the information technology
world the Chinese law applies to every
Chinese citizen every Chinese company
regardless of whether these companies
are involved in intelligence matters
themselves do you think this is this a
profound problem why I've been looking
into looking into the cases against
Huawei substantive evidence you know
there's not much there so based on that
it's hard to really pinpoint the issue
forgive me interrupting it's not so much
I agree with you there's no evidence
while we up till now have abused their
power the question is what would happen
if the Chinese government which has such
legal control under Chinese law
instructed Huawei or any other Chinese
company involved with the information
infrastructure or indeed they're very
complicated systems dealing with part of
our critical national infrastructure to
put in access that would provide
information the Chinese companies cannot
refuse I believe that the US government
also exercises a greater political
control over companies like Cisco which
to which China feels equally vulnerable
but I think the real problem is don't we
have a global vacuum a vacuum of global
governance on cyber security which is
really
issue it's not just one company per se
Martin do you think this is a global
issue is this you know big past
acidities trap kind of one big power
versus another you I'm gonna control
this realm no you're not I'm gonna
control that I'm used to controlling
what do you think's going on here well
the big side the the Graham Allison
argument the big picture story is very
simple and it doesn't depend on all
these niceties we should come to the
niceties in a moment but essentially
what he's saying is if you have two
great powers neither of which will be
prepared to accede primacy to the other
willingly and particularly but not
senesce acerra lee it's not necessary
but it's probably made a little bit more
difficult if they feel they can credibly
present the other to their own people as
other different you know Sparta and
Athens was his example of course in
Thucydides case both Greek cities but
very different that sheer suspicion will
create a cycle of tension which will
lead to war fantastic modern example was
the tensions relatively modern compared
to ancient Greece is the tensions
between Britain and Germany before the
first world war and this wasn't
intentionally ideological it wasn't like
the Cold War doesn't depend on it though
it might be a factor so Graham's
argument would be that as China Rises
conflict is inevitable and so he would
point to the the election of Trump and
the way the Trump administration is
talking the sort of speech vice
president Mike Spence gave last year
which I've commented on a plane all
indicate we found the enemy now that the
truth is that so far as has been pointed
out China has not responded for all
sorts of reasons in that
wave but it might be just biding its
time crane would say so the the argument
is we're gonna go to war now that seems
to me a colossal a horrendous way of
thinking about the future and he would
agree so then you have to come to
specific issues and specific complaints
and manage them that's the point I made
right at the beginning so the issue of
cybersecurity is a first class issue and
it will have to be managed there is a
very strong sense in the West that China
is a massive state promoter of cyber
espionage across the board and of course
China feels the same about us I have no
idea of the truth of this I'm not an
expert but it's something that has to be
dealt with similarly of course all the
naval issues connected the South China
Sea and all these are issues that have
to be managed issues about intellectual
property have to be managed issues about
state-directed espionage have to be
managed so what we're going to have to
do I think is create if we don't want to
go down with using each trap way and
it's pretty obvious to me that will be
insane just think what it means that we
have to devise ways of cooperating
effectively and that means of course
admitting the real differences we have
what Graham Welton how to handle them it
will involve global regimes oversight
and all the rest of it and changes in
law that that will also be required I
think Malcolm's points are important
that's what we're going to have to do
will that be easy no but the alternative
is where we are now which I think will
lead fairly soon and I bring a amser
advice fairly soon to a pretty well
complete breakdown of relations between
the US and China and that will be a very
serious next few years I think you've
got to get this in proportion what we're
discussing at this part of this evening
is not the general question of trade
between China and other countries we're
talking about very specific area of
Chinese companies that are tendering for
contracts in what is called the critical
national infrastructure we're looking at
security issues so I'm happy with the
the wide-ranging discussion of the
system
nice trap but I'm very happy to come
back to you putting it in your shirt so
we're talking about critter which means
do you is it wise to allow foreign
companies to be actually involved in the
computer systems that will control our
nuclear power stations for example well
the answer is first of all it depends
which country they come from
it depends secondly whether these
companies could be instructed as Chinese
companies can by their government to
involve themselves in political
interference and for example in Britain
there is no such law I have to say that
would allow any British government to
instruct a British company they're
operating in China to interfere with
systems in order to meet the political
requirements of the British government
that would be illegal under British law
and under Chinese law it seems to be
something which is permitted so you've
got to have a strategy which has been
developed quite substantially in Britain
and in other countries not just to
prevent that happening but also to
ensure that you have resilience when
there is interference that you don't
have the destruction of some of your
vital public services services 5g
networks the the question of the hour
and the United States Australia New
Zealand basically deciding against
having hallway inside them what is your
view about whether UK should stand on
that well the United Kingdom's in a
unique situation for the reasons I
briefly mentioned a few moments ago
because whether we like it or not while
we are already involved in our critical
national infrastructure through their
relationship with British Telecom and
the question is whether the particular
compromise that the British government
forced on the Chinese and to be fair to
our way they accepted it they pay for it
is this daily monitoring system that
China it depends on the advice that the
intelligence agencies are giving in
Britain GCHQ in particular are they able
to say to the British government we are
comfortable with the way this monitoring
system is working or are we not and the
evidence that came out recently was that
broadly speaking they are comfortable
but they cannot give the degree of
assurance they would like to at the end
of the day the conversation because if
you're the United States don't you come
to the UK and you've been the foreign
sector in defense sectors so you know
the answers are this better than I do
doesn't the u.s. just come to that
London and say are you or are you not
our closest ally
we don't think you should have far away
in your 5g network why is it stalled why
you still talking well this is because
we are an ally we're not a subject of
the United States we make our own it is
a factory you're in your strategic line
of course of course and you know if we
were not already involved with Huawei
this is a historical fact which doesn't
apply in Australia or New Zealand or the
United States if we didn't have Huawei
at the moment the likelihood is that the
bridge government's view would be not
that different to other Western
countries but we're dealing with a given
at the moment and now you remember there
are very few other companies from in the
Western world that can provide some of
the technology how are we comply so you
that is also a constraint when you
decide do you have to take some level of
risk or can you eliminate all risk
entirely and while we're just dealing
with these security questions I want to
deal with very quickly with two further
questions one of which in a way does
relate directly to this if you are if
you if the decision of the UK is to go
ahead with hallway inside 5g and then we
have a South China Sea problem because
all these security issues are at the end
of the day potentially related I mean
we've seen that China see some things as
related the Chancellor's checker is no
longer going to China for his visit on
trade as a result of Gavin Williams from
the defense Secretary's comments on
sending in a temporary spat that is not
a fundamental change either by the
Chinese expect something dramatic did
happen in South China Sea or in Taiwan
or in Taiwan in terms of military
activities that would create issues for
the UK well that becomes very that would
be then very similar to what has
happened with Russia because of their
annexation of Crimea and their
destabilization of eastern Ukraine if a
country like Russia or China or any
other country acts and what is
manifestly a hugely aggressive way
towards their neighbors then they suffer
consequences and in the modern world
they are more likely thankfully to be
economic sanctions than going to war
we're not going to go to war with China
but undoubtedly if they act just as
Russia did there are consequences not
just for Britain or the United States it
depends on whether the international
community is willing to respond in a
combined way and you cannot bring you
into this is this something that China
can do on the bigger strategic
staged in terms of security to reassure
these partners that it is friend not foe
I'm thinking for example North Korea I
mean China as we know has a special
relationship with North Korea certainly
he's got a more special relationship
than anyone else and can it do something
to leverage that relationship to show
that it is being the global player that
is cooperative that does want to resolve
security problems in a way that works
for everybody so first of all let me
just say briefly to set the stage right
China's state opposes openly opposes
state LED espionage they have made a lot
of progress with President Xi and Obama
that was stalled because of the rising
tension so this requires greater
governance on a global scale the problem
is the trust issue the problems a trust
issue but I think we should be more
transparent on dealing with these issues
the you know the the regional yes China
is a big big country it will exert
greater influence in the region
hopefully in a positive way hopefully it
will learn how to you know develop a
certain kind of soft power in order to
reassure that its influence in the in
the region is about economic cooperation
South China Sea yes there are disputes
there have been it's a historical thing
coming from 19th century of the
territorial disputes right now and
China's stance is let's develop the area
together and on North Korea we have seen
that they have really stepped up on
pushing North Korea pressuring that
North Korea including economic sanctions
when it was necessary sorry to do so but
let me just say that this is a learning
curve for China it's the first time that
China is engaging in the world in this
fashion without the experience and
history of many let's say European
countries or the Western powers and
their experience in dealing with other
countries it's the first time so it's on
a steep learning curve issue which there
are so many aspects of these technical
aspects intensely political tensley
economic but if I'm right that we are
moving towards the world
in which the us establishment is moving
is itself moving towards a more
profoundly hostile or at least adversary
relationship with China which will be
long-lasting and I think it's what's
happening I don't think it's just this
administration they are not only going
to they are coming to Europe and saying
so whose side are you on and that of
course will include the UK even though
we are semi or soon to be completely
detached from the EU but we're still in
the NATO structure so we'll be part of
that and I think Europeans including
ourselves will have to work out whether
we want to be in this new cold war with
the same sort of relationship that we
had during the cold war against the
Soviet Union different situation because
geographically would of course a long
way away and all the rest of it but
economically Europe is an enormous
partner of China in many ways more
important than the US and it could be
forced to take a fairly difficult
position and let me remind you the u.s.
view of what is national security though
I'm not denying what my own said goes
way beyond well way just from get your
mind around the fact that the Americans
seemed to be about to declare the German
car industry a mortal threat to US
national security once you've gone there
there's really pretty well nothing that
can't be included in this into this
umbrella so the Europeans have better
decide where they want to be in-house so
to move I want to make the discussion on
to our third part because otherwise we
will get to it and and in a way it
relates to this in a choice you know in
a them or us choice that the US forces
may force on its allies or China may
force on its partners would it be easier
would the choice feel narrower with the
choice be mitigated if our values were
closer with China is there a growing
divergence between values which make
that them or us if you feel more
urgent and hard welcome well let me
illustrate in my response something that
I experienced myself when I was foreign
secretary you mentioned I was involved
in the final stage of the Hong Kong
negotiations with China and I remember
going to Beijing to see the Chinese
Foreign Minister and I went through Hong
Kong on my way there and the people of
Hong Kong said when you see the Chinese
Foreign Minister will you please tell
him that when we become part of China
what we're anxious about is not just
what we built a vet for more than one
political party in an election what is
perhaps even more important is will we
continue to enjoy the rule of law now we
all know what that means it's about
having an independent judiciary judges
the government under the law and so
forth when I saw the Chinese Foreign
Minister I passed on this message I've
been asked to give Chen Qi Chen and I've
never forgotten his reply said oh don't
worry mr. Rifkind we in China we too
believe in the rule of law in China the
people must obey the law and I said now
hold on a moment when we talk about the
rule of law it's not just the people who
must obey the law it's the government
must be under the law if it's
government's doing something illegal
they must respect the right of courts to
instruct them to stop doing it and it
works like you know he not only didn't
agree with me he hadn't the faintest
idea what I was talking about and it's
been summed up rather well this is not
what the expression I'm going to use
it's not mine but I think it was perfect
it when you're dealing with
dictatorships whether it's China or mr.
Putin and Russia they don't have the
rule of law they have rule by law they
use the law in order to entrench their
own political power as we are saying
sadly in Sinkiang the Western Province
of China where I think we're told the
law permits the Chinese government to
incarcerate perhaps hundreds of
thousands of Muslims in that part of
China now that's not rule of law that's
rule by law and exactly the same way the
Chinese government refused to allow
their own people to have proper access
to the Internet it is more censored
comprehensively you cannot put in
anything into the internet in China that
this is a disapproved off so if you ask
about what happened in Tiananmen Square
it's blocked now that is something which
makes the relationship between China and
wider world not just with the West these
sort of constraints don't exist in
virtually every other continent of the
world including Africa of Latin America
and most of Asia and so until China it
realizes that its limitations on its own
people's Liberty is so restrictive so
unusual in the modern world how can
China expect to be trusted and treated
as an equal partner as it deserves to be
by virtue of its culture and its history
and its size and its importance as well
I mean if you can deal with some of that
and also I mean I suppose I mean one of
the things that's noticeable about Xi
Jinping's era in power has been here a
growing tendency to talk about the
West's of its a foe a us-led conspiracy
locking up human rights lawyers saying
that they are you know agents of foreign
powers color revolution allegations that
kind of thing the singeing problem
Christian leaders talking about it being
a worse time than since the culture at
any time they can remember since the
Cultural Revolution it is puzzling on
the space of it isn't it that China this
growing confident power is moving
backwards in some of these respects I
think that the hope for China is the
younger generation in fact 80% of the
youth in the whole of China is online
they imbibe information for a living
with regard to information sensitivity
all you need to download is one little
click and you get Google not everybody
uses that they like Baidu
fine I do has done a lot half a million
of these these a younger generation go
study abroad every year and it's
increasing by the numbers so they are
very much about open exchange and I've
looked at surveys they're added to
towards the West is much more optimistic
I'm much more open than even can
consider you know comparing people those
were born in the 70s or 60s they believe
in horizontal networks not vertical
hierarchies they do not need political
connections to do their business and
become entrepreneurs they don't need the
local licenses in local land
and is really changing the landscape of
China what's happening today is so
dangerous setting into the mindset of
these younger generation nationalist
nationalistic you know a kind of rivalry
that kind of when sorry a kind of you
know lose-lose kind of situation is
changing their perception and I have
been very hopeful and we talked about
the younger generation but their post
80s post 90s they will become Chinese
leader in about ten years time but what
is happening today is changing that
perception and I think that is dangerous
what is happening on the ground is a bit
different from you know and
realistically the micro channels the wee
chats the kind of micro blogging there
is a lot of information exchange going
on in fact you can look at President
Xi's how careful President Xi is
treading this us-china relationship on
the one hand it has to respond to us to
avoid an outright collision with the US
and make certain kind of trade
concessions on the other hand has to
face he has to face the Chinese citizens
are you just giving up China's interest
so if he was really completely and
unrestrained he can just do one anything
you want such as some of the problems
religion we Gers incarcerated in
so-called vocational training centers
you know Christians free to worship
young people free to use Google rather
than having to do it secretly and
risking prosecution do you think in 10
years time all of that will have changed
in China the China will be politically a
much more open place so that that
they're more us choice will feel much
narrower ideologically the current
administration believes that China is in
a transition period rightfully or
wrongfully I'm not going to judge social
stability is a huge concern the Chinese
people want security and they want
stability there is potentially a cost to
that there is always a spectrum between
freedom and stability and where are you
exactly on that spectrum different
countries may choose but as I as I
mentioned where we're going in terms of
being deeply embedded in the global
network be being
very much involved in the global
technology space let me think about how
dynamic that's happening right now the
innovations that are going on the
entrepreneurial activities enthusiasm
people are doing what they're doing they
respond to incentives that's why these
Chinese companies are successful are we
moving towards a greater more open
society I'm gonna hope and bet on the
Chinese new generation Martin I mean
we've heard mention of the of the cyber
issue in terms of tech do you think the
Chinese Communist Party is going to be
able to restrain itself from perfecting
repression through tech and actually
opening up in the way that per use given
as a visual we haven't even talked about
the social credit system which is one of
the main Western Western concerns I
think first of all I wouldn't regard
myself compared certainly with some of
the people here as in any way an expert
on China's political and social systems
it would be ridiculous for me to pretend
I do Westerners are not going to like it
no they don't right it's pretty clear
it is a repressive single party
dictatorship absolutely clear they don't
like it but that's not relevant whether
I do the question is whether one can
deal with this in a sensible productive
way and in a way which gives some chance
that it will move in a more liberal
direction in the long term no more than
that it is perfectly possible it seems
to me that with new tech not you
technology we can see very clearly is a
double-edged weapon it liberates and
oppresses at the same time it gives room
for oppression as well as room for
liberation and we simply have no idea
how that's going to play out by the way
not only in China but in other parts of
the world I won't illustrate that so
clearly you can tell a story that you
can tell a story in which China end up
as the perfect Orwellian state without
the boot as it were that
the point that will be very very very
depressing but we're not going to
determine that they're gonna determine
that we China isn't ours it's this the
question is it the question to me is
this here we have this enormous power
which is not going away and with which
we in the world are gonna have to
cooperate and deal to solve a lot of
problems we care about one of the bumps
that was discussed was climate which I'd
take very very seriously
but I'm going to give me begin to deal
with it without talking to them so the
question is how do we deal with them
realistically is my view so we have to
understand where there are threat points
for us free speech of people in our
societies of matters to us so we really
want to be quite clear that that is
defended and protected espionage is a
very serious issue we have to look at
that very carefully but my view remains
very strongly that in the long run we
are more likely to get or less unlikely
I don't know how to get a China that we
will feel comfortable with and our
children and grandchildren troubles with
if we are open fair reasonable in
dealing with it and not paranoid and
crazy and some of what is going on I
have no doubt is paranoid and crazy so
and none of that rules out the obvious
fact there are lots of things going on
in China and so in other countries but
in China which I think are very very
concerning and it may turn out that 10
or 15 years from now we do have ended up
with a country which is so hostile we
can't deal with it
but at least I would like to feel we
haven't created that by our own
stupidity and I think we are moving in
that direction just one short point if I
may what happens within China ultimately
is not our business in a direct sense
it's for the Chinese people to either
live with or react against the denial of
freedom to them what is our business is
Chinese foreign policy and the way it
treats its neighbors and like all great
powers and I don't just single out China
when you're a superpower you have a
great temptation to bully your neighbors
because you have a leverage that they do
not have the British Empire did it when
we were the superpower the United States
has been doing it for the last hundred
years and China is now doing it in the
South China Sea in particular but also
elsewhere that the world can live with
it's when a country goes beyond that as
you mentioned Germany before the First
World War
it's when it actually goes beyond just
trying to bully its neighbors and tries
to impose its will against the wider
international community then you could
be in a crisis situation now we're
nowhere near we're not being that yeah
our paranoia is more likely to create I
agree with you but the more the Chinese
government destabilize what we've seen
for example is India and Japan for the
first time in their history having joint
naval exercises why because they both
perceive a common threat from China now
that is very disturbing for China as it
is for the whole of Asia and indirectly
for the wider world let's hear now from
the floor it's time to get some
questions from all of you
China friend foe fact of life to deal
with fairly I see a what let's take a
question there first and then up here
and then up there thank you thank you
very much and if the Chinese are putting
indignant pressure on us on the one hand
to let while we come into our markets
and on the other hand the satellite
evidence is pretty clear they've locked
up a million people in the Uighur
provinces with no trial
what realistic foreign policy pressures
can we exert on them to change what can
we do okay and that one would take we'll
take him three is the time and then just
much um is there an aspect if you like
of a sort of clash of cultures a clash
of civilizations if you look at sort of
Chinese philosophy particularly Sun
Tzu's the art of war for example he's
strongly strongly argues against using
direct military force it's much more
about espionage it's a much more about
using diplomacy and it's a term of
warfare are we seeing that sort of
China's actions are based if you like on
their history if you like the Ming the
Qing dynasties did the same they didn't
send out colonies into Southeast Asia
but they did sort of have tribute states
all around them is this a rational
Chinese policy that no you can see from
the past and that we in the West are
reacting very badly to because we don't
understand them are they actually much
more aggressive than they are as you're
trying to expand doubtless thank you and
a third oh yes up there I you've talked
a lot about the West in very general
terms and I wondered if you could bring
it back to the UK more specifically
because I've got some 150 entry stamps
into China and what I find in China is
an enormous interest for an affection
for the UK and I wondered whether we
can't be a bit more proactive in what we
do particularly with a very adversarial
us-china relationship okay thank you
thank you for those three let's let some
take well let's take the foreign policy
question the first question first to you
Malcolm
what can you do if one way or inside
your system and then if millions of
millions at this point but if hundreds
of thousands possibly are locked up in
instance yang what tools of policy do
you have I don't think it's realistic to
suggest that by blocking Huawei that
will make an impact on China Chinese
government's policy towards its citizens
in Sinkiang I mean the two are separate
issues and it's a mistake to I think try
and combine them but what the Chinese
clearly are sensitive to is global
opinion directed against their own
actions now until very recently one of
the most disturbing things about the
reaction to the incarceration of many
Chinese Muslims in Sinkiang purely
because of their Muslim background was
the almost total silence from Muslim
countries Turkey has now been the first
country for whatever reason
- very strongly criticized and condemned
and the problem that we've had and when
I say we the international community has
had is that many of the Muslim states
are close to China physically are able
to be bullied by China do not dare
antagonize China and therefore the
Chinese have been able to create a
government have been able to create the
impression this is all simply Western
criticism I think this is a unique
example of where the main impact on
Chinese government policy will come not
by the reaction of the United States or
the United Kingdom which is already
there but which they in a sense they can
ignore but when the Muslim world makes
the kind of protests against Josh can
you imagine if this was happening and
Britain that we were incarcerated a
hundred tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands or in the United States or in
France or in Germany the reaction that
would be from the Muslim world by said
that Muslim world I mean Muslim state
governments and with all credit to
Turkey that they have broken ranks and
have now condemned China if they were
accompanied by all the countries of the
Arab world by Indonesia by Pakistan by
other countries in the same way China
would be forced to change its policy can
you tackle the second question this
question of whether Chinese foreign
policies coming out of deep own history
and so when we kind of categorize it as
friend or foe we are using our own value
judgments and we may misjudge because we
don't understand China's history of
foreign policy I think that one does
have to study a bit more Chinese history
and world history for that matter I
think if anything compared to all the
great powers that have risen China's
rise is really quite relatively peaceful
in respect to the history China sets a
tributary relationship with the
neighbors in Trey in you know exchange
for security or protection a submission
of that kind of relationships it didn't
go around and conquer and colonize
everybody unlike others so
but but today if I may say China's not
trying to export values it's not trying
to export moral universalism it's not
trying really to export development
model because in fact it says this
development model doesn't suit most
other countries it never said this and
you guys should take up and emulate this
kind of development model in thinking
about a Chinese global leadership it
emphasizes on allowing for differences
because when you impose convergence of
values of systems that creates problems
and we have seen are much of that now
that doesn't mean that it should
countenance every kind of regime every
kind of situation that is not the case
but it does allow for religious
differences in different kind of Allah
Allah geez because in India our ideology
is to be ideologically free thank you
I'm basking can you take the third
question is is the UK nurse in a special
position here can it offer something to
help so much light to come on to the
other two but I'll be disciplined the
the such fascinating questions I think
that I have a very specific point which
I think addresses that in a way I've
made it so I can make it fairly briefly
I believe for reasons I've explained
that it is quite likely not certain but
quite likely that our great ally the
u.s. is moving towards a contained China
policy and there are lots of very
serious West American policy
intellectuals not Republicans arguing
for this and and that is an
across-the-board containment policy in
all the eight dimensions that we are
concerned and taking being cognizant of
our own interests which is that we're a
moderate sized nation for which the u.s.
is a crucial and decisive Ally which is
decided for reasons I will never
understand but perhaps people do
understand to cast itself loose from
Europe so cognizant of those
allergies I think the UK should not go
along with this policy so far as he can
it should avoid and be clear that it
avoids being the little frigate
following the battleship in this endless
because it will be endless confrontation
with China which could shape our world
in a really horrible way so that's a
fairly specific thing and when you talk
about that that of course has
implications for how we conduct our
economic policy our foreign policy how
we operate in the WTO and all the other
things we should align ourselves with
the US where there are clear concrete
interests which would be served but we
should not go along with any broad
attempt to recreate in relationship to
China the policies we had towards the
Soviet Union because for reasons already
explained I think the two cases are
totally different I agree the substance
of what Martinez said it would be
ridiculous to suggest that China today
poses the kind of threat to the West
that the Soviet Union during the Cold
War if it had not been faced up to
indeed it would have acted so that it is
not a competitor but we do not yet know
how China is going to use the new power
that it now has and the early signs are
disturbing because the early signs and I
don't just mean in relation to the South
China Sea will forgive me they you
indicated that China was said everyone
should benefit from the South China Sea
the fact is that China has a monopoly of
death taken a monopoly of control of
many of these small islands and has
built a military base on one of the most
important of them so that it will
totally dominate through its naval
forces that area that is disturbing it
is now also being much more belligerent
in relation to Taiwan and making it
clear that if the Taiwanese in any way
seek to have an aspiration of
controlling their own destiny that is
unacceptable to China and the China
would use Miller
force c-chug things were it's not mine
to stop them doing that that is very
disturbing
they have territorial disputes with
Japan with the Philippines and with
virtually every other one of their
neighbors not to mention India on the
other side of the boards that you know
while while hearing everything Martin
said that the frigate should be at the
ready turret to get him behind the
mothership of the u.s. well I don't
think at this stage the problems of
China I the threat is to either Western
Europe or indeed to the United States in
the political sense I think the main
threat of China at the moment actually
is to its neighbor to its Asian
neighbors I mentioned earlier India and
Japan cooperating for the first time in
history because they see a common threat
now what we are talking about India and
the Asian countries have said we're no
longer talking about of a Pacific's
policy in an Indian Ocean policy it is
now Indo Pacific the countries that
surround the China are seeking to
contain China and they will have the
support of the United States Navy what
Europe does is relatively insignificant
because we do not have the military
capability in the Far East that would
make a profound difference so we are in
the relatively privileged position of
not having to make a final black and
white feminist choice as early as other
people well it would be premature anyway
because we still are entitled to hope
the China although it's entitled to be
far more influential than it's ever been
in the last hundred years it's entitled
to that by virtue of its economic
strength and its political significance
but we do not yet know whether it's
going to exaggerate its ability to
dominate its neighbors or whether it's
going to respect the fact that power
should not always be exercised to the
absolute extremities of what it's afraid
in economics Europe is very big what you
say on security is right but on trade in
economics here it's very big let's take
some more questions thank you you
briefly touched on like the different
values and the different system between
the whites and China let's just assume
China will became continued to be a
dictatorship and Westerners continue to
be democratic unless you China doesn't
exact their power excessively to their
neighbors just state contort do you
still think what's important to some
come work with China in terms of develop
economies and trade and globalization
well it seems like why some world likes
to impose their democratic assessments
to seems like everyone should be kind of
follow the same system but that a right
way to say a way a law in different
systems for different countries and you
can still work together
waste different systems thank you okay
in China you can't go into the internet
and buy a Bible you can't go to a church
unless it happens to be state controlled
registered one what is to be done about
the fact that China is doing its own
citizens basic human rights like freedom
of religion and freedom of association
thank you and the third one it was up
there
hello I'd like to ask Martin about his
point about to containment of China or
integration of China from the
perspective of the UK just as some you
know when a small company is merged with
a large company it's not really a merger
but a takeover is it not true that in in
the relationship between sovereign
nations when a large sovereign nation is
integrated with the small sovereign
nation it's not really an integration
but a relationship of master and
servants and is that not the situation
that would apply between the UK and
China if the integration that he's
talking about were to occur thank you
and a fourth
yes thank you don't you think that after
brexit and the
perhaps disintegration of trade between
Europe and the UK it's only right that
rather than complaining about things
that will probably never be able to
change in China instead focus on a
pragmatic relationship and realize that
the best way to cooperate with China is
to increase trade rather than try to
focus on their domestic policy which we
won't be able to influence okay thank
you so
divide up those for welcome can you take
that the first one why are we trying to
impose values on China why don't we just
accept that China is the way is where
the way we are and just get on with it
well first of all we're not trying to
impose values on China we couldn't
succeed envy did want to do that the
Chinese people will either demand these
rights or they will not what I would
take exception to is saying that the
choice is between the Chinese system or
what the questioner referred to as
Western values which implies that
because democracy and the rule of law
originated in as it were the
Mediterranean that somehow they're not
relevant to the rest of the world well
if that was true you would not have most
of Asia applying the same rule of law
and democratic systems not identical but
comparable to the west and just think of
China's own neighbors Japan South Korea
Taiwan Indonesia India these are all not
Western countries but they their peoples
have chosen and work successfully to
implement what the questioner called
Western virus they're not universal
values and it is no more right to say
you can't have democracy in China
because democracy was invented in Greece
than to say you can't have Islam in Asia
because it was invented in the Holy Land
yeah or Christianity was invented and
Palestine therefore it's not relevant
for any other part of the world it's an
absurd argument and the same applies to
democracy and the rule of law these are
not Western values they're universally
and Co you on the second one Bibles in
China availability why is it harder well
I think the question was about religious
freedom and human rights and I think
that absolutely religious freedom is a
form of human rights that human rights
is also broadly measured in terms of
access to education access to health the
fact the hundreds of millions people
were lifted out of the poverty as a
young woman you can walk down the
streets in any city and feel safe these
are all part of human rights and I
completely agree China's current
Challenge is what is the ethical code
what is the moral foundation of society
given that religion you know that the
kind of Chinese philosophy was that was
was underpinning this and that eroded
over time so now there's a lot of active
active church activities going on
underground that is not to say that the
Western institutionalized religion is
without problems
I think China's trying to find and
encourage more Buddhism and absolutely
religious freedom is is one of the
aspect but not the only one and I hope
to see change as well thank you immortan
a relationship of master servant is
there a danger of that from your your
suggestions and advice I could think I
can deal with the last two together
there won't be very happy because in
fact they go together rather nicely you
see because the probiotic relationship
would under this hypothesis be to become
this this slave so I think the answer to
that question is that a sensible country
tries to have certainly one located
where we are to have very close
prosperous and mutually beneficial
relationship with lots and lots of
countries some of them bigger and some
of them smaller and the likelihood is if
you look at our future that we are going
to end up very highly integrated despite
our best efforts still with Europe with
the United States which will remain a
huge power with China with India which
we haven't mentioned and many other
countries and if we are in the position
that we can have good relationships
economically with all of these countries
we won't be slaves to any of them I know
some people think we have been a slave
to Brussels I suspect not so many will
think that a year or two from now
and do you do you really think we've
been a slaved a slave of the United
States in the last 70s maybe you do but
if you do think that I don't think it'll
be any worse with China the the crucial
point is we're a country of 60 millions
trying to do our best in the world and
we cannot do whatever we like no we can
we make everybody behave the way we
think they ought to bathe and therefore
I am very definitely with the last
questioner the sensible way of looking
at the future is pragmatic I used to
think the British were pragmatic I've
given up that I here we're gonna take
just one last round of questions and in
that idea of diversifying or you know
where we place our security and every
other aspect of ourselves let's
diversify hunt flowers bloom I want to
hear more from Chinese in the audience
please honor here's some Chinese voices
and and some more women so I'm sorry men
and I'm sorry of your white man but if
so if we put a woman up there that would
be great and over here yes so let's
start start up there you know what do
you think it will take for China to lead
in climate change in a consistent and
structural way thank you
let's go to number one there and why are
the Chinese despite being enormous ly
successful and prosperous some of the
gloomiest people according to a world
happiness rankings they rank 86 out of
150 which is right after Russia and a
few water and water on countries I'd be
interested to see why that's the case
thank you and yes number three a really
small question we all know like China
are now posting like the built in road
and also the investment in African
countries so and I also know some
commentators they compare these foreign
policy behaviors like
the new Marshall Plan so I went to
asking your opinion about this opinion
thank you I think we're gonna have to
stop at three because we're running out
of time so climate change what will it
take for China to lead constructively
who'd like to pick that up let me just
make one point on climate change if I
made the Chinese government denied that
Beijing had a pollution problem until
the Chinese public forced them to change
that view and it was curiously how it
was done the United States put on its
embassy building um some equipment that
could monitor the pollution levels in
the atmosphere and announced each day
what these pollution levels were and it
became compulsory for the whole of the
population of Beijing to find out what
these figures were and eventually the
Chinese government surrendered and said
yeah okay we have a terrible pollution
problem which they totally denied until
then implying it was no worse than
anybody else's and since then my
understanding I'll be corrected if I'm
wrong is that significant improvements
are now in place now all credit that was
the Chinese public actually forcing the
Chinese government very rare to do
something they really didn't want to do
and that could be a very important
precedent okay use that how you see that
I mean the the question almost started
from a position that Jonah wasn't
leading constructively on climate change
but actually for in the beginning of
this evening you seem to be arguing that
it that it was so can you give us your
view on China and climate change
leadership well just look at the facts I
mean half of the global investment every
year on renewable energies undertaken by
China it's doing three times that of the
US Malcolm is absolutely right there has
been a lot of improvement and the
citizens have played a huge role
I think that's progress that means there
is feedback and there's the government
has been accountable on that front and
it will continue to lead in the
renewable energy industry or going
forward and I'm not going to ask you the
question about gloom can I can I answer
the belton road first because I think
it's very important
90 billion dollar deficit in
infrastructure in Africa every year
China's really the only realistic
country to be able to support and
helping that it's up to the nations
themselves how they're gonna use this
financial support they could consume it
and run into domestic debt crises as
many other developing countries have in
the past or they can invest in in
infrastructure and human capital and
spur economic growth so it's not just up
to the Chinese won't be willing to
provide that financial assistance but
it's also in the control of one brief
point on that I mean certainly one of
the questioners mentioned should it be
an equivalent to the Marshall Plan
there's one fundamental difference when
the Americans launched Marshall Plan
they provided grants not loans that had
to be repaid to the devastated countries
of Europe China's massive investment is
on the basis of debt and we have already
seen at least a dozen recipients of that
largesse now protesting Malaysia is
canceling Sri Lanka had to give China 90
years leasehold of one of its naval port
why is it all done as debt and not as
leave that question hanging Martin I
heard you were you were you were nodding
I'm gonna let you have one word on
Belton Road when I say one word you can
have a sentence I wanted to know why
Chinese people say they're so unhappy I
would just say that their ranking on
happiness is more or less their ranking
on GDP per head so maybe it's not so
surprising it's very very important we
have missed this China is an enormous
country and it's therefore an enormous
economy but it's still a really quite
poor country it's not poor as it was but
its GDP per head in real terms is about
a quarter of u.s. levels about a third
of our level in other words it's roughly
where we were 60 or 70 years ago so
that's very important to remember they
think they're a developing country and
they're right hold up
VRI is something that could be the BR I
could make a very big positive
difference at the moment my view is we
don't know whether it will thank you
well that was a very concise sentence
done how you glue as much as we can
trust surveys and relative Fri and
frames of mind we've taken that is given
but you know I come back to this what is
the spiritual foundation in the Chinese
society I do think that is a very
important question it can no longer for
some period of time it came from
prosperity and attainment of material
wealth there has to be something else
and maybe that is what it's missing in
the younger generation the one-child
policy to which I was born there's a lot
of competition there's a lot of
responsibilities to your elders who are
you living for thank you so you way I'm
going to I'm sorry I really can't take
any more questions from all of you know
because we've run out of time I'm just
gonna ask one last question to the panel
which is really I guess where we started
to bookend it we said you know we look
back and said five years ago it was
golden terrorism win-win or the language
five years hence where will we be
Martin very briefly
we will I think be trying to work out a
relationship which isn't the naive
everything is going to be perfect
forever view of such 10 15 years ago but
isn't I hope at least and I think
probably won't be China is actually the
devil incarnate and the whole aim of
life must be to suppress it that is to
say we're going to behave in a really
mature sensible and grownup fashion now
do I believe that psyche no but that's
what I hope for so you're gonna go with
the hope rather than five years from now
we won't look as stupid as we do right
now on either side okay what do you
think um first which American president
will be around but I do believe there
will be more convergence and divergence
welcome I think we're trying to look
just yours ahead I think the most
important thing is actually the
potential relevance of belton road to
the relationship of Europe and China
yeah Europe and China for a thousand
years have had to have contact with each
other by the ceilings that huge Central
Asian landmass has been like the
Atlantic Ocean it was a barrier what is
happening now and if we look five 10 15
years ahead already freight trains are
going from China to Western Europe every
week I mean increasing numbers in both
directions so what that means is Europe
and China could be looking directly at
each other and in a way that Europe and
North America were able to do because of
air travel and because of breaking the
Atlantic no longer as a barrier became a
bridge so that would be a historic
change regardless of the politics China
and Europe being able to look directly
to each other and trade with each other
in that way that could have massive
implications lovely thought to end on
that I want to just take the last show
of hands from all of you so we're kind
of 90 minutes on and we're going to take
it this time as a friend a foe war a
fact of life we have to treat fairly I
think that was Martin's Martin's
summation of some kind of category error
middle ground so who thinks China is
at the end of this 90 minutes discussion
thinks China is a friend to us can
someone run the numbers for me
fewer than before Markham says who
thinks pho also few who thinks fact of
life we have to treat fairly and that is
our winner so well done you're all very
reasonable you're gonna muddle along in
a Martin wolf version of the world thank
you all so much for coming and thank you
instead the great evening
[Applause]